certaines sources affirment qu'il aurait
crié allah akbar est ce que vous
confirmez ou pas et les informations qui
viennent de m'être communiqués à
l'instant et qui résultent des premiers
témoignages confirment effectivement que
cela aurait été prononcée donc la
violence ne se déploie il était connu
pour des actes de délinquance et il
n'était pas connu pour son implication
dans des activités terroristes et sa
situation n'a décrété judiciariser ne
faisait pas l'objet d'un suivi
particulier pour avoir participé à des
activités terroristes
individuellement ou en lien avec
d'autres acteurs vingt-quatre heures
après la mort de bertrand the one eye au
devant le commissariat de jouer le tour
le 20 décembre 2014
c'est un témoignage qui vient semer le
doute sur le déroulement des faits et la
motivation de celui que l'on appelle
dans le quartier de la rabière
bilal il était essayé de le faire
rentrer au posthotel il voulait pas donc
ils criaient et puis à ce moment là il a
sorti son couteau et puis les ont
visitées à 4 sur lui puis c'est là sont
les rails pas maîtrisé donc ils
commençaient à hésiter son couteau et
puis là ils ont tiré qu'à pas le hockey
à ce moment là et puis après ils sont
tous sortis sur lui puis vlan il ya
aucun moment elle a crié au dialogue pas
un témoignage qui jette dès lors comme
une ombre sur cette affaire l' enquête
sur les circonstances de la mort du
jeune homme est confiée au procureur de
la république de tours
quinze mois plus tard le dossier bouclé
pour la première fois il s'explique
après coup j'analyse les choses la façon
suivante il y a eu d'un point de vue
j'allais dire
des médias un élément important qui
était en direct le témoignage d'un
témoin qui a souhaité rester anonyme
et ce témoin a dit un certain nombre de
choses que l' enquête n'a pas confirmé
mais ce témoin ne s'est pas présentée
comme témoin dans la procédure
donc il a fallu le chercher et donc on a
fini par l'identifier il a été entendu
il a maintenu ce qu'il avait dit devant
les caméras mais ça n'a pas été
confirmée du tout par les éléments de
l'enquète telles qu'elles sont sortis à
l'issue de cette enquête 48 heures avant
la mort de bertrand aubriot un différend
entre des jeunes du quartier est l'un
des policiers du commissariat bien
ajouter de nouvelles interrogations
on évoque un policier connue pour ses
méthodes musclées
étonnamment et quittera joué-lès-tours
le lundi suivant
en l'état il est pour moi il n'y a aucun
doute
et personne n'a jamais pu venir me dire
le contraire alors que j'avais fait un
appel à témoin que il y a un lien entre
cette agression du policier deux jours
avant en civil d'ailleurs il était hors
service
gc voilà et l affaire proprement dite du
commissariat il a été muté il était en
il était programmé pour changer de
service et pour faire une formation
comme maître chien si mes souvenirs sont
bons savez c'était vraiment le hasard
autre interrogation des témoins qui se
présente comme tel à thèze et la
présence de caméras sur la façade du
bâtiment
pourtant cela paraît incroyable mais
elles n'existaient pas à l'époque ça je
crois que c'est vraiment quelque part à
ces caractéristiques du fonctionnement
de l'administration française
il y avait des caméras sur l'arrière du
bâtiment pour protéger d'un éventuel
cambriolage mais pas de caméra je crois
que maintenant il y en a il y en a
pratiquement dans tous les commissariats
depuis cette affaire-là
mais à l'époque il n'y avait pas de
caméras sur le devant du commissariat
joué-lès-tours donc on peut pas sortir
des bandes qui n'existent pas les seuls
bandes qu'on a pu les exploiter en
partie ces les bandes de caméras du
tramway bien sûr en y regardant de plus
près le procureur comprend l'emballement
médiatique
l'enquète a bien confirmé l'acte isolé
de bertrand aubriot mais les enquêteurs
eux-mêmes ont eu ce sentiment de tout
doute que j'ai eus que les enquêteurs
ont eu en disant mais bon est-ce qu'il a
eu un moment de folie mais bon on
s'aperçoit bien aussi à la lumière
malheureusement de ce qui s'est passé
par la suite des attentats qui s'est
passé par la suite c'est que des gens
sont prêts à mourir qui est un contexte
c'est évident et contexte de la rabière
et un contexte du commissariat de la
rabière
et il ya aussi et moi je ne le cache pas
ce point de vue c'est qu'il est
extrêmement compliqué de comprendre
qu'un individu avec un simple couteau a
attaqué un commissariat
c'est pas logique et c'est la raison
pour laquelle notamment on a cherché en
terme de l'analyse sanguine et de
toxicologie voir si éventuellement il
n'était pas sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants de choses comme ça parce que
c'est pas logique si on intègre si on
intègre ce phénomène là que l'auteur est
prêt à mourir pour la cause
ça peut s'expliquer bien avant la
conversion de bertrand aubriot à l'islam
sa mère avait sollicité les services de
police craignant de voir son fils tombé
dans la délinquance
je rappelle que si la justice a connu
monsieur ngoyo c'était la demande de sa
mère au départ parce qu'elle a bien
senti qu'elle ne maîtrisait plus et
qu'il partait dans la petite délinquance
donc voilà il y à il y a des des
personnes étaient fragiles qui ont
trouvé dans ce nouveau contexte
de quoi illustrer de quoi se faire
connaître quoi quelques pas existé et
c'est je pense vraiment en ce qui
concerne notre affaire de joué-lès-tours
c'est vraiment un acte isolé alors
qu'ils étaient vraiment bertrand ndzomo
nahio un garçon fragile sous influence
un jeune d'un quartier sensible est
défavorisée en pleine errance et en
quête d'identité ou au contraire un
jeune homme profondément radicalise
c'est là où demeurent l'ombre d'un doute
dans quel sur l'effet est donc bouclée
en revanche l'enquète anti terrorisme
menée par le parquet de paris elle n'est
pas terminée
dix mois après la sphère du commissariat
de joué-lès-tours quatre hommes ont été
interpellés en relation avec la faire